people ask me that question all the time
what it feels like to get hit
it's like a little explosion in your
body if they hit you at the right spot
but i'm not really trying to hurt them
actually except when when i'm hitting
the body i really like hearing people
like drunk
there are
very few
female boxers that are still in the game
that have the longevity in the sport
that i've had
in 20 years of boxing i've never been
knocked out much less knocked down
and i think the reason for that is not
just because i'm strong
it's because i don't take punches
i'm never there to get punched
it's weird it's very hard for me to
associate being world champion with my
name i mean i have an office that has my
belt and
all these photos of all the different
titles that i've won
but
i
just don't feel like it applies to me
i was a dancer
so
only when i
was injured
and knew that i couldn't dance anymore
that i
took up something else just for exercise
so went into kickboxing
and eventually into boxing
because i started out as a dancer one of
the biggest elements that i bring into
my boxing is movement
when i first came into boxing
there are very few women
and the mentality of the guys that were
here were that you shouldn't box you're
too pretty to box you know go back to
dance or something else this is a sport
like any other sport
i can do it
any female can do it
the best
recognition i had
was when someone said she
fights like pernell whitaker or muhammad
ali they didn't say i fought like a
female
i'm 48
and for my next fight i'm gonna try to
be the oldest
female
title holder and that would be in the
guinness world record so there's
different things that i need to win
there's different things that i need to
do and world champion is just one of it
you